does history morality favor the left or
the right I Kris is the next Vicar I'm a
next rots gift what when I was the
trotsky's of course I had no morals at
all which is the whole point of it that
you you you set out to do what you
thought was right at the expense of
anybody or anything that got in your way
and how they ever been in a position to
do it I would have done terrible things
to my opponents on those grants because
I believed so profoundly that I was
right
and one of the reasons why I am now
oddly enough in the same church is Kris
Bryant is because I decided to put a
stop to all that I didn't think it was
legitimate anymore to believe so
strongly that I was right that I could
even think of treating people as I would
have done had I successfully achieved
the Bolshevik Revolution which I sought
so actively in the 1960s and 1970s
so morality in politics seems to me to
be dangerous the other thing about
morality is it seems to me to be
increasingly as I get older and nearer
and nearest being dead that it seems to
me to be very much about yourself and
not about other people the best
definition of morality I ever came
across was morality is what you do when
you think nobody is looking and the
people sometimes get quite shot when I
say that and but it is it seems to me an
honest appreciation of what it's about
what politicians can do about morality
is they can quite often push people into
doing things they don't want to do
because they the politicians think those
things are right or they can stop people
from doing things that they would
otherwise like to do am i great beef
about this is that over the past 50 or
60 years almost every piece of
legislation social or economic has been
designed to make it harder for people
unless they're very rich to raise their
own children and particularly for women
to stay at home bring up the next
generation rather than going out and
being wage slaves I will I will say one
other thing that the left over that
period have tended to take the view
that's simply by holding the opinions
they have and being on the side of what
they term progress they are themselves
moral and that those who don't know
their views which I don't themselves
immoral so I take for example the fact
that I happen to think that capital
punishment is sometimes justified in the
case of heinous murder now you can argue
about this with me and you can disagree
with me about it and I will happily take
you on but the reaction of most
self-described civilized persons in in
London to any suggestion of that kind is
to recoil like a salted snail from me as
a person because I am so evil that I
hold this view and this seems to me to
be a major problem in public discourse
you cannot really debate against anybody
who despises you and I'd find that it's
very difficult a lot of the time to
actually hold the base because very
rapidly the rules of reason and logic
and the the presentation of fact in
support are you flies out of the window
and it becomes about who and what you
are and that seems to me to be a major
problem with almost all modern political
discourse the left think they're right
and not nearly that they think they're
better people
you